net neutrality was repealed last week we
now have impending price increases
increases announced by at least three
major Internet service providers we've
got Comcast Cox and frontier all upping
various rates for 2018 now to be clear
these Internet service providers up
their rates all the time I'm not saying
they are doing this because of the
repeal of net neutrality but this is now
something they will have even more
freedom to do
we've got Comcast that has launched
instant TV to TV streaming service
they're going to have a new three to $3
and 50 cent per month fee added to it
they're gonna increase modem rental fees
by 10% missed payment fees will go from
50 cents to $10 then you've got Cox
cable they're going to up most of their
monthly internet plans between two and
four dollars a month and that's of
course separate from the price increases
on their cable TV plans and then you've
got friends here Communications which is
adding a completely arbitrary and
sketchy $2 Internet infrastructure
surcharge to most accounts include
including the promotional deals and
that's how they do a lot of these pseudo
scams where they quote you a really low
price like the sticker price $29.99 a
month but then they shift a ton of the
money they collect from you into the
fees that they mix in with the taxes
there and this is a really really common
thing so let's think this through is
this because of net neutrality well no I
mean these companies raise rates all the
time the problems here are numerous
though number one is that of course now
these increases that we deal with every
year are going to be allowed to escalate
and become even more expensive the
possibility of tiered internet plans
internet fast lanes and slow lanes as
we've talked about second is the
deceptive advertising of the low sticker
price which I mentioned and then
backloading all the fees and the number
three is that entire scam that is
technology fees and infrastructure fees
the way digital technology is supposed
to work over time is that the technology
costs decrease bandwidth over time
becomes cheaper data storage over time
becomes cheaper as more customers get
Internet the distribution cost
per customer goes down these fees exist
in part because of the market power that
these companies have because they are
effectively legal monopolies my service
just went up I called in they offer me a
savings of $10 a month if I'm willing to
slow down my internet to half of its
speed by the way my Internet's already
slow and how is the customer service -
oh it's atrocious
it's absolutely atrocious in New York
City this is not a victory of any kind
it's not a progressive panacea but there
was a little bit of competition in
Manhattan
so in our Manhattan studio we had
Verizon FiOS fiber-optic service for $85
a month it was a 100 megabit down 50
megabit up really great we were able to
upload our big 2 gigabyte Daily Show
file in like 10 minutes
oh hi in Boston we have Comcast recently
went up from 165 bucks a month to two
hundred and fifteen dollars a month for
a 20 megabit upload line that's the
fastest that we can get unless we want
Comcast to put in a fiber line for us
which would still only be a 20 megabit
upload but it would be more stable as
the sales pitch goes and that would cost
$700 per month No thank you and this is
not praise for Verizon it's just the
reality that as soon as you get some
competition you do start to see better
options at lower prices and it is going
to get much worse before it gets better